all right let's talk about what i'm
wearing look how cute i look right well
it seems like have you dressed for an
occasion yeah can everybody just totally
take me in look do you see who's it's my
drew barrymore look at this all on me
and i know drew it's a look that's
really raising eyebrows
for those those of you at home who are
jealous right now don't be because you
can get yours right now at guest stores
and guests.com right now drew look at
you i know like this is my face all over
this jacket and these jeans but it's
such a cool interpretation i really have
to give it up to guests
this was a campaign i did with them in
the 90s hence the eyebrows
and it's a partnership between a company
called pleasures and la streetwear brand
and guests
and
this photographer wayne mazer and i and
this model werner verner he is like the
german james dean oh no you don't
understand he would walk in the room and
we'd all just be like there he is german
james dean
look do you remember kissing do you
remember you know i tried so hard uh to
get him to pay me attention outside of
his
job yeah um but he never like i never
saw him out with like he just was this
unattainable god yeah well you're not so
bad yourself i mean look i've always
said you had good genes but literally
oh
all right we got to talk about this you
know even in a pandemic people are out
there right now they're figuring out how
they can date and now on refinery29 they
report there's a new trend called
apocalypsing this is dating during the
age of a covid a survey of 2 000 singles
found that people are getting real
serious real quick they're deciding like
it's hard to meet somebody i'm going to
meet you and we're just going to rush
this in and make it happen they're
moving so fast that
the fears are they're overlooking some
red flags because it feels like because
the worlds are going to end they're just
going to fast forward it and snuggle
what do you think about this
well i think that swiping was too sort
of like dismissive like there's so many
fish in the sea the grass is greener i'm
just gonna keep looking and i do think a
lot of good candidates went by the
wayside
this might be
too impulsive
but i think maybe it's gonna land in the
pretty little middle which is maybe
people just need to take more risks and
see things through and give it a chance
and a try and i feel like we've just
been in such extremes for so many years
i really do believe in that pretty
little middle and you do have one life
and you can always get out of it and
just be willing to take those risks so
maybe this is a really a good thing you
know what i was so glad to hear i
thought you're going to be like poo poo
this idea but i actually think you know
relationships are really uh tested in
stressful situations right yep so if you
meet somebody and you can survive a
pandemic with them maybe there's really
something great there you know a lot of
us like to wake up next to somebody ross
it's not the worst thing in the world
it's certainly not
but should it be your dog well now
that's the question and i know we want
to talk about this well the atlantic is
asking is it okay for your dog to sleep
in your bed and the writer says sure
it's hairy and gross and her dog has
puked on her duvet twice so i think she
knows what she's talking about
and uh but she loves it and she says it
doesn't ruin your sleep and a study
found that women who slept with their
dogs reported more restful nights than
those even slept with humans or cats so
ross
i know this is a thing for you let's get
into it you've got three dogs i do i
have three chihuahuas that look at my
three chihuahuas they're
all combined they add up to one real dog
but you know i sleep with them in the
bed every single night which was great
when i was single right because that you
know they're like a little alarm system
right built in but then i got you know
in a relationship uh it's been a year
now and it was
no there's no there's a brand new no
dogs in the bed rule uh and if i break
that rule i'm i'm thrown in the doghouse
someone throw me a bone
i'm trying to really unleash these dog
puns but it was a it was a thing where
my partner put his foot down and said no
like the bedroom needs to be special it
needs you know we and i have to tell you
i do sleep better without them really i
really do i mean there is something to
it they're waking up in the night
they're jingle jangling their collar i
didn't even realize i was doing it until
they weren't there and by the way you
know these are rescue dogs i got them
really nice beds i i stopped feeling
guilty about after day two
you know um how old are they also
they vary but i mean really nice beds so
i didn't feel bad
you know what i say put the man first
you're taking great care of the dogs and
listen nobody wants that eye contact
either like if you're making out and
that dog's staring at you ill
they can rule the roost of the rest of
the house and i'm i'm i'm i buy no guilt
no guilt
absolutely not okay
now something i really could have in bed
with me
it's so funny because i know what you're
talking about is so true
it's craft macaroni and
it's my favorite thing and it's by the
way if i'm having stress i totally turn
to mac and cheese it's like i have one
in glass break you know for an emergency
um and they are launching craft is
launching a new recyclable cup so that
this orange wonder
is going green good for them and fox
business reports that the new
fiber-based cup is microwavable and they
promise that every craft product
will be recyclable reusable or
compostable by 2025
and
i just you know i
if we talk about news you can use ross
yes this is
the best day ever well and i feel like
every company it's this is the
responsible thing they've got to figure
it out and if you just when you thought
you didn't love craft mac and geez you
couldn't love them anymore look what
they did for you
and listen there is a really cool new
thing out and ross you're going to tell
me about well i actually saw about this
okay um i know you're a craft deluxe
girl through and through and so i i want
to make sure you saw this have you ever
you like the kind with the packet of
cheese right that's the one well first
of all thank you for asking i am a whiz
girl i'm fine with the powder milk and
butter although everybody kind of has
their own ratio i hate when it ends up
milky and watery that really peeves me
off yeah i um but uh no i'm a full wiz
like aluminum packet girl yeah the only
problem with the packet is sometimes i
find and you guys we've all been there
that you can't get it all out right well
uh check this out it's the latest mac
hack on tick tock this woman is a genius
and she found out she cracked the code
take a look this is her getting every
drop of cheese out of that little packet
drew i know you look at her face i know
by the way i'm like the dog at the end
of the bed i'm like
well guess what drew just when you
thought today couldn't get any better
look
i have mac and cheese for you right over
there and we can try to do that mac hack
yes girl
see if we can do it we've opened the
cheese packet okay place it here under
the lid there's cooked noodles in here
so we're putting like the end of the
packet under the lid you got it and then
put the lid down and now pull it out
secure it and then
pull pull
there's nothing left
oh my god thank you ma'am oh
[Music]
you